I used to be a respected scientist said
by name the sides of buildings now I got
this you wanted a smaller quantum tunnel
this is smaller what sorry my dad no I
think it has Flair all right
trolls online the collection unit
activates when you decouple it it should
automatically start absorbing quantum
healing particles also make sure you
stay out of the tardigrade fields
they're cute but they'll eat you and
don't get sucked into a time vortex we
won't be able to save you okay
going subatomic in five four three two
one
alright Scott this is a Mic Check Mic
Check one two one two
how's everybody doing tonight in the
quantum realm god
we read you I just want to make sure
[Music]
okay
dealing particles secured for our new
ghost friend great preparing for
re-entry
in five four three hello ha ha very
funny Hank quit screwing around you told
me yourself not to screw around Hank
Oh Janet guys
guys
okay seriously don't joke around bring
me up let's go guys so this is a scene
we cut from the movie it is Hankey Jenna
in the quantum realm I really quite like
this scene they're making their way back
to the pod and she's explaining a bit
about the quantum realm just a hint and
they come upon this quantum creature a
very large threatening creature and
Janet knows how to handle her business
it was important here to sort of show a
scene where there's no combat but she
has this device this piece of technology
that's similar to say the Babel Fish and
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy that's
able to translate it she's able to sort
of broker a temporary peace deal with
this creature and it moves along she
assures them that they're just passing
through and you see Hanks reaction there
which is quite fun
[Music]
hey everybody its Charley Marvel's
dropping high quality versions of the
ant-man of the wasp post-credit scene
leading into Avengers 4 as well as the
director's commentary on that quantum
realm seem so I wanted to do a new video
about that there is so much big Marvel
news that dropped this morning the
Spider Man P is for a game giveaway
still going on all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
Marvel related comment on the video uh
name a new winner at the end of this
we've been talking about the
post-credits scene for a while now
ant-man getting stuck in there obviously
coming out in the future because there's
a bit of a time jump at the beginning of
Avengers 4 there's a lot of different
rumors about how much time passes
especially given what black widows hair
looks like in all those behind the
scenes pictures we've gotten most
important knowledge bombs dropped by
Janet Van Dyne are at the idea of time
vortices which is just a plot device to
get ant-man into the present day of
Avengers force he sort of wanders his
way around because he's the one person
in that scene that is not a scientist
like Janet Van Dyne completely
reconfigured her suit to survive down
there she macgyvered herself a
communication device that allowed her to
talk to alien or non-human creatures
down there you'd have to figure out
their language first then you would have
to find the parts for that within your
own suit so not only is she
cannibalizing parts from her own suit
she's also physically adapting to live
down there and understand to get while
it's all happening love did he name drop
Hitchhiker's Guide now Scott Lang gets
stuck down there he just spends a lot of
time bumping around wandering now there
are obviously three ways that he can get
out of there one he could accidentally
just bump into a time for to see and get
sucked out into the future which is
where he meets all the Avengers 2 he
could bump into one of the quantum
beings that live down there they help
him find a way out he still falls into a
time for to see and winds up in the
future in 3 somebody else from the
outside helps him get out like his
daughter Cassie Lang if she's gonna be
an older version of herself she
obviously seems very capable and
intelligent maybe they have a funny
repeat of the plot of ant-man the wasp
like where they're communicating with
Janet Van Dyne down in the quantum realm
where Cassie does the same thing with
her father Scott but the other big thing
that everybody has been talking about
since the movie came out was people have
been saying that they see fan o's
in the background when he's collecting
these quantum particles most of them are
referring to when the frame is blue here
but because we have this nice
high-quality version you can actually
see like there's really no pattern there
is an inkblot situation you kind of see
what you want to see because the
patterns are shifting so much I think
they were already referencing so much
Thanos finger-snap in this moment here
and teasing so much Avengers for to come
so you don't actually need to be so on
the nose that you put Thanos face down
in the quantum realm here and that's not
really how the Infinity Gauntlet works
even though there have been comic book
stories where Thanos is powerful enough
to exist in all places at once those are
sort of non-canonical the Infinity
Gauntlet doesn't allow you to do that it
just gives you the power to affect the
universe simultaneously which is part of
how the time gem works in concert with
the other gems because if you want to
get really scientific about it
Einstein style time is moving at a
different rate at one end of the
universe
than it is at the other so the power gem
amplifies the effects of the time gem so
that you can actually freeze time in an
instant across the entire universe so
that when he snaps his finger and turns
everyone to ash it's happening at the
same time everywhere the thing that they
changed about infinity war though for
dramatic effect is that some people turn
to ash faster than others which isn't
really the way that it would happen the
way the writers and the Russos tried to
explain it as is as some of the
super-powered characters like spider-man
or Captain America were physically able
to resist it briefly for a second before
they turned but really that wouldn't
have mattered like they would have
instantaneously turned so it is more for
dramatic effect like we see this
character turned then we see this other
character that we love turned to ash
then we see another character and
finally that spider-man moment at the
end we get a slightly different version
of this Janet Van Dyne deleted scene
earlier that I talked a little bit about
the big teaser here is that she's just
like many many worlds within the quantum
realm talking about how it's connected
to the multiverse
so everything that Janet Van Dyne talks
about in her brief scenes during the
movie there was definitely not enough
Janet Van Dyne teased multiverse
[Music]
so there is a video that I'm working on
about mutants in the MCU in her quantum
healing powers and how her body has
changed while she was down in there
that'll probably post later this week
because that gets into the Fox Disney
stuff because obviously we're gonna get
x-men and legit mutants in the MCU but
the way Marvel has been setting itself
up since Scarlet Witch was introduced is
that they already have mutants it just
they couldn't use that term illegally
because it belonged to Fox because of
their copyright but no worries Disney's
dropping their big Aladdin trailer
tonight during football so let me know
if you want me to do a video about that
there's a whole bunch of other Avengers
for stuff that dropped this morning
about brie Larson's Marvel contract Thor
in rocket wearing special new armor
including Captain America so I'll try to
get to everything in the next couple of
days I'm still working on venom Easter
eggs so that'll post really soon just
let me know which videos you want me to
post first no worries congratulations
Marcus green you're the giveaway winner
from my last big video please email me
on the about page of my channel so I can
get your contact details we're all
hoping for Adam warlock soon click here
to learn about the guardians of the
galaxy scenes during Avengers 4 and how
they've changed click here for that new
venom carnage teaser thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]